this video game you're not very uh not
much of a fan of Kevin vanard why no
this is uh the legend of Kora which I'm
trying to get to a good spot I think the
review went up this morning three out of
10 uh three out of 10 yeah yeah I think
this game is pretty bad so you're saying
that as far as Platinum Games go it's
not quite as good as Bayonetta 2 how
does a studio follow up Bayonetta 2 with
this game I don't know I don't think
this would be I mean this really is the
kind of game where you know that they
had like a fourman team working on it
and had like 20 minutes to finish yeah
um so I'll just start wherever it is cuz
I was I was doing some uh some stuff
here in Antarctica in the South Pole for
folks who don't know this is uh based on
the sort of Avatar spin-off TV show
right yes yes and I have
seen all of the episodes I have uh I I I
was a little late getting to Avatar but
by the time I had finished Avatar cor
then was on the air and I even saw the
awful ight shamal and Shyamalan Shu
movie I haven't seen that is it really
is it is it terrible it's the worst
thing that's ever been associated with
the Avatar Universe really what is it
about video games what's some marrow
okay I guess but like there's been some
Avatar stinkers like does this game at
least allow you to get all 1,000
achievements in like 5 Seconds no but
that was fun when we were able to do
that no I I mean the movie I mean is the
worst thing in in all of Avatar things
like this is this tries its best but
what's interesting is you're seeing
stuff that you won't see if you the
first time around like you don't get air
until relatively late so a move so most
of the platforming that you do so you
get all four bending techniques but you
don't get you don't have them all until
over halfway through game Like Beckham
and then air yes okay yes so no well no
it's it's uh fire water air and Earth
okay and Har and hard and
donet again my is that a Titan so what
make what makes it so is it boring or is
it bad it's or is it both it's both a
lot of the time I mean a a lot of it
comes down to the rep oh my God the rep
the repetition you know the Cameron lock
on don't you know they have a hard time
catching up fire just sucks I hate doing
that and then you you you just battle
these Mecha tanks all the time over and
over is it difficult he he's just rep
repetitive well sometimes it gets
difficult because then you have to deal
with that kind of
stuff so the game just loves taking
control away from you like that just
really into
that and so you get these
guys you know use you're totally going
to get murdered you know that I am the
good news is when it happens I'm going
to be able to access the store um and
this is where IO a buying iro provides
over this he's like mamasa ninja Guiden
except it's Uncle iro I mean to me he's
Uncle iro he's you know he's zuk Uncle
iro I've got some candy for you but you
want to collect you want to collect your
your orb so that you have
the you know the currency to buy
different things like that and in case
I'm buying some health items to help
keep me alive so straight up linear
action game it's a linear action game
how long is it um took me maybe I mean
not not counting stops and starts like
when die which happens quite a bit in
this game not necessarily because it's
all that hard but because the way it's
hard is pretty cheap um and then it has
these like endless Runner sequences that
are just the worst thing
ever oh just chok between levels yeah
it's like you're on the you're on naga's
back and then and then you know it's
just it's just running levels where you
automatically
run you can do this Kevin I've been
think Shadow Mor
all week and it's got a pretty
forgiving uh but but fun uh varied uh
combat system H this looks like a real
hot
garbage I mean it's not this is one of
the the worst examples of it usually
it's just pretty shallow and it looks
cool and I I really love it when they
make it so I can't see
anything this is going to do nothing for
the oh he just doesn't know how to play
it right people in the
comments man I'm wearing a Dark Souls
shirt I don't want anybody to tell me I
don't like hard things wait shut up shut
up I hate all of you I hate all of you
shut up all right shut up somebody break
that out will they yeah gift that and
then have John Cena come in and or Randy
Orton coming and RKO
someone